it's about
time we are coming at you with facts oh
you gotta love good evidence-based
tick-tock
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we're going to be looking at five
nutrition and weight loss facts from
tick tock that sound a little bit like
bs but are actually evidence based okay
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor buildbar so if you know you know
that i do enjoy me a build bar on the
regular because i mean they're packed
with protein and they actually taste
like chocolate because they're made with
actual chocolate
and you know what i always say about
this zero guilt on the package unless
you stole from a baby all foods are zero
guilt foods and these delicious little
nom noms are definitely no exception so
today's flavor
am i wanting fruity i'm not wanting more
sweet
we're going with the peanut butter
brownie
feels like a brownie day doesn't it oh
yeah anything peanut butter is my jam
oh this is my jam this is my turn that
song off this is my jam
it's like a reese mmm
it's so good a reese with 19 grams of
protein cannot complain about that
oh no i probably have something in my
teeth but so yummy um and these are a
low sugar bar so when i need like a
solid complete snack for post workout i
always like to pair them with some fruit
or toast or oats or something like that
so if you want to try these out yourself
check out the link in my description and
then use my promo code abbiesharp15 to
get 15 off of your order now before we
get too into it feel free to pause the
screen or look in my description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey also if you're new here don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode and since we're
talking tick tock today if you haven't
already followed me there get on it at
abby's kitchen i mean please do not
discount us elder millennials ability to
throw down some killer talks for ticks
can we short form that no okay cool
moving on young cherups moving on first
up let's watch this tick tock from t
walk to hulk fitness i think that's how
you cool cats say it yeah are you cool
cats and kittens the best fruit you can
eat if you're
experiencing bloating the best food in
general it's going to be kiwi that's
because it's high in fiber so it's going
to help move food through the digestive
system a lot more efficiently and
effectively and also it has digestive
enzymes in it one in particular is
called actinidin and this one is
scientifically proven to help digest red
meats and dairy specifically a lot more
effectively than any other digestive
enzymes so throw that into your diet if
you have an issues and fill in that
bloated filling especially after large
meal okay so if you're a regular abby's
kitchen viewer you know to get your
wellness culture bs bingo cards ready
anytime an influencer says the words
anti-bloat
honestly in a world where it's now kind
of socially taboo to talk about
intentional weight loss i often feel the
influencers use reducing bloating as a
bit of a cryptic code but if you watch
my videos on the low fodmap diet and
sibo i can tell you that actual
legitimate bloating is really no joke
and while something as simple as eating
some kiwi may seem like wellness culture
bs it's actually evidence-based so first
of all kiwi fruit contains 5 grams of
fiber per cup which alone makes it a
great choice for promoting regularity
and therefore relieving constipation
that can lead to painful bloating more
specifically though kiwi contains a
unique proteolytic enzyme called
actinidin which research suggests may
help to enhance protein digestion so one
study compared eating kiwi with eating
either prunes or psyllium fiber which
are two other commonly recommended foods
for constipation and they found that
while all three help to improve bowel
movement rate stool consistency and help
to reduce straining only the mighty kiwi
helped reduce uncomfortable bloating and
the best part is it didn't require any
kind of expensive supplement it
literally just took two kiwis per day to
see results i feel like that's totally
doable for most people kiwi also had the
fewest side effects like abdominal
discomfort since kiwi are actually low
in fodmaps meaning they're appropriate
for folks with ibs who might otherwise
be sensitive to a lot of high fiber
foods now i'm actually going to be
talking a lot more about this in my
updated sibo journey video to come but
two dietitian colleagues that i worked
with on this actually recommended adding
two kiwis daily to my protocol so this
is something that i personally have some
experience with myself and it is way
more tasty than some kind of strange
unregulated anti-bloat supplement and
it's also evidence-based so i say fact
checked okay so next let's take a look
at this video from m spec nutrition we
have yet to talk about the third pillar
of health sleep in stress but that's
sort of lumped in research consistently
shows us that those who get less than
six and a half hours of sleep each night
are at a severely greater risk for
obesity and overweight than those who
get more than that six and a half hours
of sleep but madison that makes no sense
it has no effect on calories in our
calories out well it could indirectly
some of the research actually points
towards this lack of sleep affecting
hormones when i say hormones i mean
hormones that are in control of
inflammation in your body like cortisol
or hunger and fullness cues like leptin
and ghrelin glucose metabolism like
insulin and so much more yep our fellow
dietitian maddie is absolutely right so
there's actually a lot of quality
research suggesting an association
between the numbers of hours we sleep
and our weight over time so for example
one six-year prospect of study based in
quebec found that compared with average
duration sleepers those who slept less
than five hours or those who slept more
than nine hours a night were 35
and 25 percent more likely to experience
a five kilogram weight gain over six
years respectively findings from other
cross-sectional and cohort studies via a
large meta-analysis also suggests that
under sleeping is strongly and
consistently associated with obesity
with the association being strongest in
younger age groups and then waning over
time with age one reason why this may be
particularly important is that some
studies suggest that this added weight
tends to be predominantly visceral or
abdominal fat which is more
significantly associated with chronic
disease than subcutaneous fat why well
again our girl maddie definitely knows
her stuff it largely has to do with the
association between our circadian rhythm
and our hormones so ghrelin which is our
hunger hormone and leptin our satiety
hormone are impacted by our sleepy
hormone melatonin when melatonin is high
leptin gets released explaining why
generally we can sleep for like eight
hours without being awoken by ravenous
hunger but sub-optimal sleep can
definitely mess up these hunger signals
so one study found that after just two
nights of four hours of sleep
participants had 28
higher levels of ghrelin and 18
lower leptin in their blood than
participants who slept 10 hours a night
now the sleep deprived participants also
had 24 greater self-reported hunger and
23 greater appetite levels not ideal
obviously if you're trying to lose
weight now another satiety hormone
peptide yy also seems to be affected
with research suggesting a decline in
levels after sleeping just five hours a
night for two nights now aside from the
impact on appetite hormones it also
seems that chronic poor sleep can also
lead to metabolic changes that favor fat
gain and muscle loss so sleep
deprivation is a huge stressor on the
body which can cause our stress hormone
cortisol to rise now cortisol basically
works in opposition to that sleepy
hormone melatonin so when one is high
the other's low and vice versa
throughout the day now it's completely
normal for our cortisol to be highest in
the morning when you're kind of supposed
to be getting up and going but
chronically high cortisol levels can
prompt the body to store more fat and we
do tend to see this in the research so
one study found that dieting
participants who slept less than five
and a half hours a night lost the same
amount of weight as those who were
sleeping eight and a half hours a night
but the sleep-deprived folks lost mainly
lean tissue while the well-slept folks
lost mainly fat so getting that sleep in
helps to build and protect that
metabolically active muscle now i want
to take it back to melatonin for a
second because it seems that our natural
circadian rhythms may be getting a
little messed up as a result of how we
live in modern society most notably from
the blue light emitted by all of our
gadgets and tech so research suggests
that the use of blue light emitting
electronic devices before bed seems to
prolong the time it can take to fall
asleep delays our circadian clock
suppresses our melatonin levels reduces
rem sleep and reduces alertness the next
day so not surprisingly other research
suggests a significant association
between the use of light emitting
electronics and obesity over time this
is why it's a common recommendation to
try to power down in the hours before
bed and i know it's really hard because
well you're probably using your phone or
your ipad right now to watch this video
but it may actually make a huge
difference for your health other reason
for this association between poor sleep
and obesity are more practical i guess
so it's worth pointing out that the more
hours you're awake the more
opportunities you may have to eat
sleeping is kind of like a forced fast
if you will i mean if you have dinner at
6 p.m but you don't go to bed until
midnight there's a greater likelihood
you're gonna want to have another meal
or two than if you were to have gone to
bed at eight like some of us cool cats
do
so it's possible that that also plays a
role and then we also have to consider
the effects of poor sleep and poor rest
on our desire for activity one study
found that after just two nights of four
hours sleep subjects had significantly
lower activity than those who got a
solid 8. no sherlock i mean i don't know
about you but i don't really feel like
doing a boot camp after a night of
continual counting sheep
[Music]
now there's still a lot to learn in
terms of the underlying mechanisms of
this relationship and like everything in
nutrition research it is not without
confounding variables either but i do
think we can all safely say that sleep
is pretty important for our overall
health so i would way much rather people
focus on sleep hygiene than on fasting
windows or magical supplements or bogus
food combining rules so i would say fact
check all right let's now move on to a
tick tock from luke hannah nutrition
spiking insulin in excess could
absolutely make you gain weight any
research at all on it will confirm that
you sure about that one champ for those
who don't know insulin is a hormone that
is released by the body to help push
glucose from our blood into our cells
many people believe that this stops us
from losing weight if we spike it too
much as per this comment so let's have a
look at the research shall we study one
compared a high carbohydrate plant-based
diet to a keto diet they found that
despite high levels of carbohydrates and
therefore high levels of circulating
insulin the plant-based group actually
ended up eating far less calories and
losing more weight therefore this study
does not align with a carbohydrate
insulin model and this study put
strength trained males on either a high
carb or a low carb diet for 12 weeks and
they found that if you match calories
and protein the changes in body
composition are going to be similar this
meta-analysis looked at high carb versus
low carb studies on those who are
overweight or obese and when it came to
body composition and biomarkers of
health they found no significant
differences between the two diets this
one study actually looked at what
happened when you put people on a very
high sugar diet and despite the fact
that one group had 50 percent of their
energy intake coming from sugar this did
not stop them losing weight and these
are just a few examples trust me when i
say there are plenty more that came from
so unless you have specific medical
conditions such as insulin resistance or
pcos you do not need to worry about
spiking insulin and preventing you from
losing weight okay so this is in fact
true since the popularity of diets like
intermittent fasting and the keto diet
we have heard an overwhelming amount of
disdain for
all things insulin the keto dieters
insist that insulin is a fat storing
hormone and is solely responsible for
why you're gaining weight or not losing
weight and while i know that we all love
a good scapegoat the reality is that
it's just not
true wrong wrong wrong wrong
yes insulin does tell fat cells not to
break down fat because if there's a
readily available source of
carbohydrates there's no need to break
it down but as this trainer and
nutritionist suggests anne backs up with
actual research spikes and insulin will
not absolutely result in subsequent
spikes in weight to really dive into
this i spoke to my colleague eric
williamson who is really an expert in
the field of intermittent fasting in
addition to the studies that this tick
talker mentions eric pointed me towards
another 12-month randomized control
trial which found that when equal
emphasis is given to high dietary
quality for both low-fat and
low-carbohydrate eating plans it's not
helpful to preferentially direct an
individual with high insulin secretion
status who's seeking weight loss to
follow a lower carb eating plan instead
of a lower fat eating plan in other
words the researchers checked insulin
sensitivity and found that those who
secrete more insulin than those who
secrete less do not lose weight faster
or slower regardless of whether they are
on a low or high carb diet this refutes
the carbohydrate insulin model which
would otherwise suggest that those who
secrete more insulin would lose weight
slower or would benefit more from a low
carb diet so yeah insulin just doesn't
really matter all that much in the
general healthy population now that of
course is in a highly controlled diet
experiment in the real world a diet that
causes your blood sugar or insulin to
rise and fall very likely could make it
more difficult to lose weight but that's
not because insulin is this big bad fat
storing hormone it's because a diet rich
in refined carbohydrates is more likely
to cause more significant increases in
blood sugar and therefore insulin and
when these things fall soon again after
they make you hungry again now compare
that to a diet rich in i don't know the
hunger crushing combo where we're
combining carbs with protein fiber and
healthy fats you're just gonna find it
probably easier to manage appetite and
eat fewer calories therefore maintaining
a caloric deficit with more ease but you
know if calories are equal a high sugar
diet doesn't make you gain weight any
more than a low sugar diet but in the
real world with real humans
eating just sugar will make you feel
less physically satisfied which will
make maintaining a caloric deficit more
challenging and on that note back
checked next let's take a look at this
clip from dr carl and warning folks you
may fall in love with this man
chlorophyll water fact or cap is
supposedly increases your blood cells
cures cancer
and even detoxes your liver
but there's a big problem chlorophyll
water doesn't even contain chlorophyll
real chlorophyll does not dissolve in
water but if you replace its magnesium
with copper you now have a water-soluble
chemical called chlorophyll in
health food products containing
chlorophyll are not regulated so you
have no idea whether they're
contaminated with arsenic or even
plutonium the side effects include
diarrhea photosensitivity and even
changing the color of your poo and there
are no studies showing that it actually
really really works if you want real
chlorophyll eat vegetables that have a
green skin and a green flesh
chlorophyll water cap oh my god
can we just talk about how cute this man
is
i don't even know if the accent the
shirt or the fact that he is crushing
diet myths left right and center but i
want to be adopted by dr carl or at the
very least do some kind of tick tock
collab but anyways yeah this chlorophyll
trend is total bunk he is absolutely
right now i think the hype is based on a
few small studies which suggested that
it can clear up your skin and reduce
signs of aging but all of these studies
looked at chlorophyll as a topical skin
treatment and not something that you
ingest in water there's a difference
there was also one study with just 22
endurance athletes who took chlorophyll
for four months and found that the
athletes who took it had more platelets
than those who didn't interesting yes
but the researchers didn't actually
measure how the athletes felt or whether
they performed better so we don't even
know if this has any actual impact in
real life lastly a study using rats
suggested that chlorophyll but not
chlorophyll in might inhibit signs of
colon cancer but like our friend carl
says that green tincture the us has
spent 6.7 million dollars on in 2021
alone isn't even real chlorophyll it's a
semi-synthetic mixture of sodium copper
salts derived from chlorophyll called
chlorophyll in and as he said there are
some side effects to be worried about
like gastric upset photosensitivity
sunburn and a rare rash called
pseudoporefirea
i don't know but it does not look like a
day at the spa so not only does the
stuff not cure cancer but theoretically
one might argue that it may actually
increase your risk of cancer if you're
chronically getting sun damaged and
burned now obviously this is me being a
sassy [ __ ] and i really don't think
that the risk is high enough to warrant
any kind of concern but i say that only
to point out how ridiculous these
wellness influencers claims actually are
finally as we discussed in my video on
supplement regulation right here it's
kind of the wild west when it comes to
supplements like these they are not
regulated by the government at all so
it's really left a consumer to find a
product that's been third party tested
for purity and contamination and even if
the product is third party tested that
only assures you that it contains the
chlorophyll in substance and not
something dangerous like arsenic but it
does not tell you that it will clear
your acne or cure cancer because
ultimately it will not so if you want
actual chlorophyll like he says and not
some synthetic 30 tincture just do what
your mama said and eat your damn
vegetables things like spinach collard
greens alfalfa parsley broccoli green
cabbage asparagus green beans and peas
are all great inexpensive sources of
chlorophyll that come packaged up with
fiber and flavor sounds like an obvious
choice to me fact checked finally let's
talk about this video by dr ids how much
protein do you really need for muscle
growth and if you want evidence-based
health advice then hit that follow
protein is essential for all bodily
functions including enzyme hormone
function and of course to make some
gains for general health we should all
be getting at least 0.8 grams per
kilogram of body weight but to optimize
muscle growth a common recommendation is
to have one gram per pound or 2.2 grams
per kilogram some studies suggest that
having above 2.2 grams per kilogram is
optimal but the issue with this study is
that they only had two groups the first
group had one gram and the second group
had 2.3 grams per kilogram this means we
can't ascertain the point at which
adding more protein becomes pointless
plenty of evidence shows that having 1.3
to 1.8 grams spread across three meals
is optimal and going beyond that is
unlikely to provide any additional
benefit the exception to this is when
you're in a calorie deficit or losing a
substantial amount of weight a
systematic review suggested that going
above 2.2 grams per kilogram may be best
to minimize muscle mass breakdown yes
yes and yes yes yes
so this is such a highly asked question
that i threw my own hat in the ring to
answer this one myself in an ask abby
video right here but here's the thing
depending on who you ask you're going to
get super different answers and that's
because the research we do have
including the studies that he lists are
often
relatively small and in some cases
they're done on very specific
populations like athletes or other
physically active individuals now what i
can pretty confidently say is that the
current rda of 0.8 grams of protein per
kilogram of body weight is literally the
bare minimum to prevent malnutrition and
when there are literally only three
macronutrients that we need to focus on
do we really want to invest the bare
minimum in the macronutrient responsible
for our enzymes hormones muscle function
and metabolism i don't know i just think
it deserves a little bit more effort so
the exact amount of protein each
individual needs will be highly
individualized based on body composition
goals sex activity etc but here are some
general guidelines to get you started
now for healthy but sedentary young men
as well as older men and women a lot of
authorities suggest around 1.2 grams per
kilogram of body weight for athletes a
current meta analysis suggests that
we're looking at between 1.6 and 2.2
grams per kilogram depending on the
sport and goals for muscle gain we're
looking at between 1.6 and 2.4 grams per
kilogram and for general fat loss while
in a caloric deficit studies and
recommendations range from anywhere
between 1.6 to as high as 3.1 grams per
kilogram so all that said i do agree
that somewhere in the neighborhood of
1.3 to 1.8 grams per kilogram is more
realistic and sensible for most people
though needs of course may be different
and greater for those with very specific
goals having said all that the total
daily amount is probably less important
than the amounts consumed per meal
especially if muscle growth is your goal
so you'll want a meal or snack of around
0.25 to 0.4 grams of protein per
kilogram every three to four hours to
maximize muscle protein synthesis and
yeah i know all of these numbers are
really stupidly overwhelming but here's
the convenient truth if you're eating
three meals and a few snacks per day and
including a source of protein in those
meals and snacks you're probably doing
this naturally without even thinking
about it so as an example for someone
like me that could be a 7am breakfast
with three quarters of a cup of greek
yogurt with a banana and some granola a
10am snack of like an apple with two
tablespoons of peanut butter with a
tablespoon of hemp hearts uh 1 pm we got
lunch we got some chicken a sweet potato
some veggies 4 p.m we got 2 hard-boiled
eggs and like a piece of fruit and we
have dinner of a salmon fillet with some
brown rice and broccoli and that is like
the upper end of those ranges for
someone my size ultimately your needs
are going to be unique and this is why i
do recommend working with a registered
dietitian not just following advice from
random people online because even the
most evidence-based content creators
don't necessarily know you or your
unique needs and i bet that all of these
creators that i mentioned right here
would agree with that so on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today folks thank you again to buildbar
for sponsoring this video if you liked
it be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me comment below on what you'd
like to see me talk about next subscribe
to this channel and i will see you next
time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you